you
this year's year's price award studies
of how the DNA code is translated into
life the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to award the 2009
Nobel Prize in Chemistry jointly to
Professor Venkatraman Ramakrishnan
professor Thomas Stites and professor
auda
Jana and the Academy's Citation runs as
follows for their studies on the
structure and function of the ribosome
and professor ramakrishnan is working at
the MRC laboratories in Cambridge in the
United Kingdom
professor Stites at Yale University in
New Haven Connecticut USA and professor
you're not at the Weizmann Institute of
Science in Rea about Israel
you